I don't think the fashion does matter in
the workplace i think what matters in
the workplace is self-expression
individuality and creativity using
fashion as a way to communicate
something about you it's among women
much more of a narcissistic culture we
don't just follow trends anymore we're
looking to create our own look
Einstein's philosopher o is a great
example of having that signature
flourish without it he's unrecognizable
so voila there's a great style lesson
there my top three tips for lab techies
are as follows eyewear eyewear eyewear
is the number one nine times out of 10
that's all people see if you is your
head bobbing above a cubicle or a lab
bench so your eyewear should be very
extraordinary and the older you get the
more larger your eyewear should become
you should end up like mr. Magoo with
these just giant or Yoko Ono you know
huge shades color in the techy lab
environment you see a lot of people
wearing gray and beige and sham beige
and sham page as well you know there's
nothing wrong with a bit of orange
orange looks great with dark brown pale
blue looks great with dark brown just
like experiment a bit more with color
it's life enhancing for you and for
those around you so in a way it's a form
of politeness number three for women
false eyelashes while other girls were a
beauty school learning to glue on it
lashes and you know these super smart
science girls were too busy you'd head
in a book trying to sort of absorb this
massive amount of information that they
need to get their career going so to
take a step back be that chick who was
at beauty school learning to glow on
lashes it's very transformative and it's
kind of meditative and soothing I
wouldn't know personally but the girls I
know who do it tell me